who sold him this because Hollywood did
yeah but so when I look so when playing
demand so when we're talking about it
I'm thinking about
um our demographic I'm thinking about
obviously our community that's what I'm
thinking about yeah when did we ever
prescribe to Hollywood selling us this
this white wedding and this and this um
this Prince Charming fairy tale like I
don't I don't understand where it's come
from because it's not something because
we're consumers okay so and we are
probably one of the biggest consumers so
we consume a lot of things we consume
and women are one of the biggest
consumers and debt consumers yeah so
many we we spend more even though we
make less we make 70 to 80 percent of
consumer buying decisions so roughly 10K
less so I've always said never
underestimate the ability to sell a
woman a dream no I would like women get
Soul dreams on a daily basis like they
watch
um the Kardashians they watch Jay-Z and
Beyonce they watch Sierra they watch
Rihanna and they continuously dream
because he was saying in In that clip
right about Hafiz was saying about oh
one percent and there's a 99 and it's
like for me he was having very
um female talking points from totally
honest yeah I like Tony mentioned
Patrick but David that's someone that
obviously that that I follow on social
media and obviously I like the way he
said I'll put in talks about how he came
from obviously rather than coming
American doing all the different things
in his family unit so I understand what
you guys are saying about how danger it
is for men but I'm just still talking
from a point of where I have okay so in
my friendship group minimum amount of
people that are married but the ones
that are the ones that are the
relationships are strong and you can see
why they married and obviously they've
got their kids together and the family
and then but the ones that haven't the
amount of dysfunction already that is
there it's like it is that was there
even before before anything else so when
I'm looking at what I see personally
um so would you would on looking at that
clip would you be on do you think you'd
be on the side of her fees or coach Greg
Adams no so
um
was he going to talk about Patrick by
David and that talking about store he
was the one in the suit yeah who's the
one Advocate Advocate yeah yeah yeah so
him you'd be yeah because I I just
I know it's a risk everything that you
guys say it makes sense like I'm not
stupid like it all makes sense but at
some point I'm still willing to put that
risk up like I could be one of those
people that could be saying later or
nothing like oh man don't do what I did
that was foolish but at the same time I
would still say I put that risk out and
I went out there because what I've seen
in my life what happens by having a
strong family unit and a good woman in
your life in actual fact you do way more
coming from my sisters being those types
of women coming from my mom being that
type of woman how old are your sisters
uh this my younger sister is 33 and then
they go up got from that age yeah okay
yeah so
um like growing up from what I've seen
all my sisters and obviously not just my
sisters my family like the ones around
and like yeah I've seen more dysfunction
in people that haven't been been married
and and I also think it's the type of
girl that you marry as well right
there's some girls that that's what they
were saying yeah so I think there's some
girls that marrying is a come up for
them like it's a it's a dream you know
like it was so far away from them for
for out of their league and then you'll
pick them and you're chosen to get
married and you're chosen to yeah but
you can't you can't find a girl that's
not going to be influenced by the
culture no and so you can't you can't
take away social media you can't take
away TV you can't take away not any of
that I'm not saying to take it away but
I'm just saying end of the day is like a
lot so like I'm saying women are roll
the dice yeah women women women are
master manipulator in general no I'm not
just I'm not disputing I'm so demanded I
I think men in this Society are less
manipulated by the social media or
they're less manipulated by women are
addicted to social media men are
addicted to video games right exactly
yeah like we'll complain always on video
games okay what's your screen time yeah
and so if if men are being influenced
generally by computer games and women
are being influenced generally by social
media and they both come together right
my thing is online gaming no no
we speak about traditional relationships
you know I mean we have these shows we
but if the generations are not even both
of them both men and women are not even
looking to be traditional like the men
are I've always said men have lost their
purpose young boys are engrossed in
computer games young women are engrossed
in social media and corn yeah computer
games and corn that's what young men are
engross in women are engrossed in
um social media and corn also as a
matter of fact right so what happens
when you come together this is why I'm
talking about nutritional
um our traditional relationships dead
because I don't think either side
understand what it is to be in a
traditional relationship I'm curious
from YouTube what did you guys think of
the clip
I don't really have much to say about
the clip because I was listening to it
but not fully like it wasn't I wasn't
really focused okay for being honest
okay what about you same here to be
honest yeah so so are you guys on your
phones yeah yeah see there you go social
media
like are you Pro marriage like are you
Pro marriage or
your promise you don't want to get
married one day yes but it's just not
something that's in my foot right now
I'm like I've got many years to go until
I think about marriage howdy 22 why
would you say many years because I just
feel like I'm not where I want to be in
life like I'm not aware I want to be in
life so I need to work on myself get to
that position and then I can more focus
on men but right now men it's not my
main focus because I've got things that
I need to do I'm not where I need to be
in life yet so if you if you were to get
a man do you think that you'd know what
a man wants in a woman
yeah which is because obviously I'd be
dating doesn't mean that I want to get
into relationship no but just at this
moment do you think you know what men
want from a woman right now yeah
not everything but most things
we'll name some stuff name three things
that you think men want from women
someone that's family orientated someone
that's ambitious
and
show love and affection is that a good
enough answer for you no I'm just saying
like
um a lot of the time when women speak
but the reason why I'm asking these
questions is it was quite probing is
because a lot of the time women think
they know what men want and they
actually don't men don't care if you
remember they don't care I promise to
God they don't care about it I'm telling
you I'm very ambitious I work very hard
like I put this whole podcast they don't
give a [ __ ] there's no way you can
struggle to get a man like what's wrong
with you nothing so so I know so what
you're what you're doing is yeah you're
you're judging women you're judging men
how you look at but we don't actually so
we don't care about if you're ambitious
you care for man's ambitious yeah for us
you have an ambition doesn't doesn't
make it what we care about it's like a
shoe collection so we care about guys a
shoe collection you don't care right
yeah so we can't so that's that's what
it is to make our work we care about how
you look we care about loyalty
um femininity and low body count that's
these are things that most okay can I
just say something about the low body
count why do you care so much about a
woman's body count because you men you
can be like 20 and your body counts at
50 and you might get a good girl that's
only that only has a body count of two
and what like what are you doing because
because historically men had to ensure
paternity it's like we can't we have
biological reasons for the for the
reasons we feel the way we feel like
women like muscles and we like tall men
because we want a guy to protect us
right but men like a girl that hasn't
slept around because
um they could ensure paternity
historically because we didn't as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible